have 20 don't we confirmed cases in the
uk
so far but that bound to rise and is
that concerning
um well it is at first not so much
concerning as it is unusual and i think
that is what has people concerned
normally we would see sporadic sort of
travel associated cases in europe and in
the uk but this type of large outbreak
is quite unusual and i think that is why
people are a little bit more concerned
than they would normally be
so tell us why it is so unusual it's
spreading in the community isn't it
that's giving cause for concern
um so basically normally you would have
these one or two cases
um whereas what we are seeing now is
human to human transmission so that
means that people who have very close
contacts with
each other um so contacts with bodily
fluids um close skin to skin contact
that that that is spreading within the
uk that's what we're seeing right now
and this is affecting men is it
primarily from what we've seen so far
well there seems to be a
disproportionate risk among the
community of men who have sex with men
we can't at the moment say exactly why
that is um but that is certainly what we
are seeing in the numbers right now
just remind us how monkey pox presents
itself and what it can mean for people
who get it
um so initially monkey pox will are
present with a fever headaches sort of
backaches muscle pain
and just generally not feeling quite
well and then you see
the typical rash so i think we've all
seen the pictures that uk hsa has shown
and
that is then what kind of then scraps
over and
eventually falls off
um so that's how it looks like and the
the pictures actually show that on a
number of different skin types which is
quite nice so that people can recognize
it
from what we are seeing here at the
moment in this country these are
believed to be mild cases but perhaps no
guarantee it will stay that way
um so generally speaking monkey pox is
what we call a self-limiting disease so
people will get it it will get quite
unpleasant as i think everyone can
imagine from those pictures um but then
it will sort of run its course
now there is what we call a case
fatality rate of between one and four
percent for the west african clade of
the virus which is the the clay that we
see in the uk right now um however that
is under quite different circumstances
from what we have here so that is in our
very resource limited settings
what is being used to treat it is it the
smallpox vaccine that we understand and
i suppose that can only have so much of
an effect
um so i mean we we need to differentiate
here between treatment and prophylaxis
um so treatment for monkeypox is
primarily symptomatic and aims
to reduce the likelihood of these skin
lesions becoming infected by bacteria
in the uk at the moment the
the smallpox vaccine is being used as a
pre and post exposure prophylaxis so
that means for a very select group of
people who have either a very high
likelihood to get exposed so certain
healthcare workers or who have been in
confirmed contact with someone who's had
um
monkeypox they might get offered the the
smallpox vaccine as a prophylaxis
and is that a general thing
in many countries or just here given the
fact that even today president biden has
come out and expressed his concern about
it in america
well at the moment technically speaking
the the smallpox vaccine is a smallpox
vaccine it's not a monkeypox vaccine um
so it will be up to each individual
country to decide whether they would
like to use it off label um for
monkeypox and then even further on it is
up to
each individual and they're treating
physician whether the the risk benefit
ratio is good for them whether it is
something that is sensible for them so
we're not talking about a vaccination
sort of at population scale here as we
did for covet
if somebody's got it or fears to have
got it i mean a rash could be anything
couldn't it but
what should they be doing or going to
their doctor getting some kind of advice
i think contacting a healthcare provider
is certainly the
advisable option if you think you have
it or you you think you have been in
close contact with someone who has it
and are people going to have to be put
into isolation when they do have it to
to
try to mitigate any risk of it spreading
well that to a certain degree is a
question of the jurisdiction um and a
question to be to be had sort of from a
government point of view whether that is
something that should be mandated
as as individuals it is certainly
advisable not to have any close contacts
if you if you have confirmed to have
monkey pox